[Music]
jennifer starts off this hour in
philadelphia hi jennifer how are you
hi dave hi rachel how are you guys great
how can we help
so my husband and i are on baby step two
and
i'm looking at the seven baby steps and
i had a question about baby step five
not to jump ahead but
um my daughter is 27
and i just found out about you in my
defense in march
so she has student debt about 70 000
um because mom didn't pay for it i had a
different perspective prior to listening
to you
so my question is when i get to baby
step five should i help her pay off her
student debt or is it now her
responsibility because mom didn't help
sooner
although i did give her 15 000 with my
husband's help on her room and rent
um
i don't know if i've ever had this
question before
it's an interesting perspective though
because usually it's the
27 year old that calls us and says i'm
debt free i paid off 70 000 student loan
debt uh because technically you know
it's her debt that she took on yes was
the guidance from you
unknowing
helping her into that situation of debt
yes um
but to a point i'm like i
it it was her that did it though do you
know what i'm saying it was her that got
the education
off on some of those loans with her
because again i had a totally different
perspective
totally are you are you a co-signer now
is that what you're saying
no she's so responsible she refinanced
you didn't sign off on anything then
well i did but then she refinanced
oh okay
okay so she has 70 000 student loan debt
what is her degree in
she is a nurse she has bsn okay
and what is she single
she is what does she make
between 80 and 85 000 more than mom
okay
you are a sweet lady
you do not owe this money you do not owe
this money
okay your daughter is um
legally morally and capable
of handling this
okay and mathematically capable of
handling it
it's not you you didn't harm her um you
didn't set out with malice to you didn't
benefit from this in some way this is
not money you stole
that was your daughter's from her trust
fund this is not anything like that she
simply went and stood i mean
if um no you're not lie i i don't you're
not liable and i want to set you free
and i got a feeling your daughter
doesn't think you're liable
she doesn't she she actually is okay
because her and i have talked about
she's okay with saying it
but i'm like you know i understand
you feel guilty
for her yeah you're a sweet lady you're
very sweet
thank you and yeah it's just um you have
a good heart and a a strong conscience
and
that's a good thing so if you were
worth 20 million dollars or 5 million or
something like that and you want to take
70 000 and write a check pay it off
that would be fine
you're not in that situation
and if you did do that it would not be a
baby step five thing anyway it would be
a baby step seven thing
right it would just be i'm helping my
kids because i'm rich
i'm not
you'll be there you'll be there someday
but she'll be out of debt by the time
you're there
so um
yeah and she's she's okay you have not
harmed her for life she's not
permanently scarred this isn't she's not
under some kind of burden she can't
recover from
you have not destroyed her
um she's fine she's going to get her
debts paid off and uh i'll tell you what
let's let's let her go through financial
peace university and rachel and i will
pay for it we'll give it to you okay
oh wow that um that would be fantastic
yeah sign her up and send her through
that and um
and just tell her that we're cheering
for yeah because jennifer too we when we
talk to families on the baby steps you
know we
we tell them that like hey if you're on
baby step you know five and
your kid is a senior in high school and
you don't have the money college is not
an entitlement and you are not a bad
parent for not helping fund college
there are ways to go to school
debt free now i understand that this is
the back end of that conversation of you
incur maybe encouraging the student
loans or telling it's not a big deal all
that so i get that guilt uh but you have
to let that go jennifer i mean i think
that you know pete we've had two calls
on this stage with people that had
student loans and they a nurse literally
in the first segment and she worked her
way out so it is mathematically possible
for your daughter
she paid off 80 80 thousand dollars and
she was 33 years old yeah yeah very very
close very close
so it's doable but i think again your
heart behind it jennifer is awesome and
i think that there could be a great goal
because you're you wanting to
um
you know
quote-unquote fix that mistake that
maybe you helped guide her in
uh maybe you make a goal for yourself
and baby step seven i wanna take my
daughter and we're gonna go on a great
vacation and i wanna pay for it and
enjoy it and make that a goal for baby
step seven you know you can still do
stuff to bless her and to love her but
you are not obligated nor
are you in a position yet to feel like
you have to cover that 70 000. that's in
her name exactly
and uh but it is nice to talk to people
with honor
and that have a conscience and that feel
the responsibility as a parent too right
because it's that feeling of like man i
messed that one up and i want to go and
repair that so that's a very honest
honest feeling but
the position you're in jennifer i would
just i would keep going along and she's
going to be okay